this is a dude competing in men's
weightlifting competitions as of 2013
after this person was competing as a
male in male weightlifting competitions
take some estrogen and now you can
compete with the females
and now we're gonna pretend this is an
even playing field let me just put it
this way to the women that is wildly
unfair
i'll tell you what is an important
moment in sport
apparently and this is it is a glorious
moment it is truly incredible
an olympics new zealand weightlifter
okay and this weightlifter's name is
laurel hubbard
will become the first transgender
athlete to compete at the olympics now
you got to love
the language here okay because the
reality is
that a normal head that so much of our
media is dedicated
to obscuring actual stories by just
changing the verbiage by just changing
the wording now the actual headline
should be if we all spoke english
together the actual headline would be
biological male to become first
biological male to compete
at the games in women's weightlifting
because that's the story
if the story were just a biological
female of any sort of
identity competing against other women
everybody's like okay that's not a story
the reason it's a story is because this
is a dude okay and this dude is a
biological male
hubbard will compete in the super
heavyweight 87 plus kilogram category
her selection made possible by an update
to qualifying requirements in may again
the simple adoption of the pronouns
demanded changes the nature of the story
because if you just read that sentence
you'd be like i don't understand why
this is a story
right if you if you just read the first
couple of paragraphs
you would not understand what exactly is
going on if you spoke english from like
two years ago
right weight lifter laurel hubbard will
become the first transgender athlete to
compete
at the olympics after being selected by
new zealand for the women's event at the
tokyo games a decision set to reignite a
debate over inclusion and fairness and
sport
hubbard will compete in that category
her selection made possible by an update
to qualifying requirements in may
hey you have to get all the way to the
third paragraph before you understand
what the hell is going on
the 43 year old will be the oldest
lifter at the games had competed in
men's weightlifting competitions before
transitioning in 2013. okay let me just
put it this way to the women that is
wildly unfair this is a dude
who is a full dude in every respect and
continues to be a full dude
just with either some surgeries or some
hormone therapy
but was competing in men's weightlifting
competitions
as of 2013 which means you had the full
bone and muscle development
of a man all the way not just through
puberty but through adulthood
and was competing against dudes in the
same category
and now we're going to pretend that this
is an even playing field and then it
makes no difference
hubbard said i'm grateful and humbled by
the kindness and support that has been
given to me by so many new zealanders
in new zealand olympics chief karen
smith said it was a historic moment in
sport and for the new zealand team
she is our first olympian who has
transitioned from male to female except
you can't
become a female after being a male that
is not physically possible
we do know that there are many questions
about fairness of transgender athletes
competing in the olympic games but i
would like to take this opportunity to
remind us all that laurel has met all of
the required criteria okay let's just
be fair about this there's there are no
honestly how many other 43 year old
weightlifters are there
in the olympics i'd love to see a stat
how many 43 year old competitors are
there in actually physically demanding
sports in the olympics you see a lot of
43 year old sprinters in the olympics
seem kind of weird maybe the reason is
because the biology is different here
gang but you're not allowed to say that
hubbard has been eligible to compete at
the olympics since 2015 which the ioc
issued guidelines
allowing any transgender athlete to
compete as a woman provided their
testosterone levels are below 10
animals per liter for at least 12 months
before their first competition so
literally
a year and a half after this person was
competing as a male in male
weightlifting competitions
take some estrogen and now you can
compete with the females
truly incredible some tie-in scientists
have said the guidelines do little to
mitigate the biological advantages of
those who have gone through puberty as
males
yeah you think advocates for transgender
inclusion argue the process of
transition decreases that advantage
considerably
and that physical differences between
athletes means there is never truly a
level playing field
um there are broad categories of male
and female
in human biology and all mammalian
biology as it turns out
but you know i'm rooting for hubbard
frankly i think that it's i think it's
great i think hubbard should win
and i think that every male who takes
some estrogen should compete in all the
female categories
and then we can truly have a more truly
diverse and inclusive
society a true meritocracy if you will
hubbard's gold medal wins at the 2019
pacific games in samoa where she topped
the podium ahead of samoa's commonwealth
games champion
fighter stowers triggered outrage in the
host nation samoa's weightlifting boss
at hubbard selection for tokyo would be
like letting athletes dope
feared it would cost the small pacific
nation a medal yes
belgian weightlifter anna van bellingham
said last month
allowing hubbard to compete was unfair
for women and like a bad joke
that is correct but um
just really really solid stuff there
from the international
olympic committee once again we have
we've created a hell of a society for
ourselves it is truly astonishing to
watch
as the new meritocracy arises
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
so you stay up to date with all our
future content